y nos dicen aquí están los resultados
del muestreo de votantes de dos
distritos vecinos ya estas personas les
preguntaron se apoyan una cierta ley o
la rechazan observa que para cada
distrito tomamos una población de 100
votantes y con esto calculamos la
proporción de la muestra que apoya la
ley por acá tenemos los datos combinados
de ambos distritos y nos preguntan esta
información sugiere una diferencia
significativa entre los dos distritos
bueno necesitamos hacer una prueba de
hipótesis y la forma en la que lo
haremos será primero establecer una
hipótesis nula recuerda la hipótesis
nula es aquella que no supone diferencia
alguna por lo tanto podemos suponer que
la población de votantes en el distrito
a verdadera que apoyan la ley es igual a
ven que apoya en la ley otra forma de
pensar es que la diferencia entre estas
dos proporciones es igual a cero
y nuestra hipótesis alternativa será que
el valor absoluto de la diferencia entre
estas dos proporciones no es igual a
cero y si estamos haciendo una prueba de
hipótesis a profundidad tenemos que
establecer un valor de significancia y
la mayoría de las veces este nivel de
significancia es del 10% o del 5%
así que establezcamos un nivel de
significancia del 5% después lo que
hacemos es suponer que la hipótesis nula
es cierta entonces dado que la hipótesis
no es cierta cuál es la probabilidad de
que la diferencia entre estas
proporciones muestrales sea así de
extrema o más y si esta probabilidad es
menos que el nivel de significancia
entonces rechazaremos la hipótesis nula
y con ello podemos sugerir la
alternativa ahora bien antes de seguir
adelante necesitamos comprobar que se
cumplan las condiciones para la
inferencia esto lo hemos visto en varias
ocasiones la primera es la condición de
aller
necesitamos sentirnos seguros de que
estas dos muestras sean completamente
aleatorias la segunda condición es la
condición de normalidad la cual nos dice
que necesitamos tener al menos 10 éxitos
y 10 fracasos para cada una de las
muestras lo cual es completamente cierto
no puedes verlo aquí por último tenemos
la condición de independencia para que
se cumpla esta condición necesitamos ya
sea que la muestra se haga con reemplazo
o sentirnos seguros de que estos tamaños
de la muestra sean menores que el 10% de
la población completa lo cual podemos
suponer lo ya que esperamos que habiten
al menos 1000 personas en cada distrito
con esto cumplimos también la condición
de independencia
muy bien ya que cumplimos las
condiciones para la inferencia
supongamos la hipótesis nula y vamos a
pensar en la distribución muestral de
las diferencias entre las proporciones
primero calculemos la desviación
estándar de la diferencia de las
distribuciones muestrales bueno ya lo
hemos visto anteriormente la varianza de
la distribución muestral de una
diferencia de proporciones esto va a ser
igual a la varianza de la distribución
muestral de proporciones para el
distrito am más la varianza de la
distribución muestral de proporciones
para el distrito ver ahora bien puedes
encontrar la varianza para una
distribución muestral de una proporción
con la siguiente fórmula la varianza
para una distribución muestral de una
proporción es igual a p que multiplica a
1 - p entre n
ahora en ambas situaciones no conocemos
las proporciones verdaderas ni para el
distrito a ni para el bebé es por eso
que estamos haciendo nuestra prueba de
hipótesis pero podemos intentar estimar
las aunque suponemos que las
proporciones verdaderas son iguales en
la hipótesis nula
aún así pensamos en que no podemos saber
cuáles son ahora viene la mejor
estimación de la proporción verdadera si
suponemos que el distrito a y el
distrito b no tienen diferencia en
términos de los votantes que apoyan la
nueva ley será la proporción de la
muestra combinada que tenemos aquí así
que para estimar estos dos valores
usaremos esta proporción de la muestra
combinada en lugar de p por lo tanto me
va a quedar lo siguiente va a ser 0.55
por uno menos la proporción de la
muestra combinada
entre el tamaño de la muestra que son
100 votantes y si suponemos que no hay
diferencia entre el distrito am y el
distrito b esta varianza estimada
también aplican para este otro distrito
por lo tanto déjame reescribir la
desviación estándar de nuevo la
desviación estándar de la diferencia de
las distribuciones muestrales del
distrito a y del b será aproximadamente
recuerda como no pudimos calcularla
exactamente usamos como estimación
esta proporción combinada es por ello
que es aproximadamente igual a la raíz
cuadrada y dentro del radical tendremos
el estimado de esto que es 0.55 que
multiplica a 1 - 0.55 lo cual es 0.45
entre 7 más la estimación de verde que
es exactamente lo mismo
0.55 x 0.45 entre 100
y ahora podemos sacar nuestra
calculadora para obtener este resultado
voy a tener la raíz cuadrada de 0.55 que
multiplica a 0.45 esto entre 100 y bueno
como le voy a sumar lo mismo yo voy a
multiplicar por 2 y esto será
aproximadamente igual a amd a 0.07 así
que esto será aproximadamente igual a
0.07 y lo voy a escribir ahora usando
esto podemos calcular un puntaje z y
después calcular la probabilidad de
obtener algo tan extremo o más que ese
puntaje z así que nuestro valor z o
nuestro puntaje z será igual a la
diferencia que tenemos p sombrero a
menos p sombrero b
esto entre la estimación de nuestra
desviación estándar de la diferencia de
distribuciones muestrales es decir todo
esto entre 0.07 ahora esto que tenemos
en amarillo es 0.58 0.52 lo cual es 0.06
entre 0.07 y de nuevo podemos tener
nuestra calculadora y ver cuánto es 0.06
entre 0.07 y es aproximadamente 0.86
bien
ahora cuál es la probabilidad de obtener
algo tan extremo o más que este valor
bueno déjame representarlo gráficamente
por acá si esta es la distribución
muestral de la diferencia entre nuestras
proporciones y suponemos que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera por lo tanto
la media de la distribución muestral
será 0 y si tenemos por acá una
desviación estándar después de la media
por acá dos desviaciones estándar
después de la media y por acá una antes
y dos antes entonces si obtenemos un
resultado que nos deja aquí y si nos
preguntamos cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener un resultado tan extremo o más
que éste bueno entonces nos interesa la
probabilidad de obtener esto que estoy
sombreando y nosotros sabemos que esto
es más que el 30% porque incluso si
excluimos una desviación estándar
después y antes de la media y sombre
ambos el área que sea más extrema que
ese valor
bueno observa estamos viendo
aproximadamente un área del 31 o 32 por
ciento entonces la probabilidad de
obtener un resultado al menos tan
extremo como
será mayor que el 30 por ciento y por lo
tanto definitivamente es más grande que
nuestro nivel de significancia entonces
será completamente razonable que
obtengamos algo tan extremo como esta
diferencia si suponemos la hipótesis
nula en los siguientes vídeos diremos
incluso más profundo y revisaremos este
resultado en una tabla zeta para
calcular estas áreas de manera más
precisa y así compararla con este nivel
de significancia pero en esta ocasión no
es ni siquiera cercano a este valor y
por lo tanto rechazamos la hipótesis
nula y terminamos la respuesta a la
pregunta esta información sugiere una
diferencia significativa entre los dos
distritos tiene como respuesta no no la
sugiere y hemos terminado